even more important than where it came
from the Chinese leadership knew that
they had a pretty damn contagious
relatively lethal virus on their hands
by the fall of 19.
and decided to put tens of thousands of
people on airplanes and murder and I say
that intentionally murder
hundreds of thousands of people all
across this country they had a choice to
make the choice they made was load
airplanes send them to Milan Italy
the Chinese Communist Party must be held
accountable for this look they don't
care about human life
so be it but when you when you transmit
that to the rest of the world and you
kill people all around the world there's
a place for real accountability
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the former director of the CIA former
Secretary of State and author of the new
book never give an inch fighting for the
America I love secretary Mike Pompeo
welcome to the Reuben report
Dave it's great to be with you I
mentioned to you right before we started
that I just did an hour show blowing up
the people of the world economic forum
and now I get to talk to an actual
American so I'm I'm very relieved at the
moment that's how we're starting this
interview with just relief on my part I
hope that's okay with you that is a
great way to begin an interview and you
did note that you are not in Davos can I
ask where you are yeah I'm I'm in my
home I'm in Virginia today great great
all right well there's a ton to talk to
you about obviously before we get into
all of the CIA stuff and Secretary of
State stuff and Trump stuff and Biden
stuff and all that stuff can you give me
like a minute or two just kind of uh
Mike Pompeo 101 a little bit of your
history that led you to doing all of
these things
oh goodness so uh look I grew up in
Santa Ana California
um my parents wanted to chart a better
life for their kids I have a older
sister younger brother much like many
parents in America and then I got really
lucky I got into West Point and so I
went to United States Military Academy
served a little over five years on
active duty I had a great assignment
Ronald Reagan was my commander-in-chief
I was patrolling the East German Border
in my M1 tank there's there's not much
better for 22 22 year old kid than
rolling up and down a Soviet communist
Border in an M1 tank it's all really
good stuff
uh and then I went to law school
practiced law for a couple of years and
started a company in Kansas with my
three best friends in the whole world uh
married to a lovely woman named Susan we
have one son Nick who's now 32 years old
and married to a great Christian lady
named Rachel uh and then I uh I lost my
mind after about eight or nine years in
the private sector ran for Congress and
uh that that led me to ultimately
getting the opportunity to serve America
in the Trump Administration in those two
those two roles all right that's the the
abbreviated bio let's say uh let me
start this way for for the real portion
of the interview uh you know right now
when people say CIA FBI when when people
are hearing all of what's going on with
the Twitter files and seeming government
intelligence agency collusion with big
Tech and all of these things there's a
real I think warranted skepticism about
these agencies so can you just talk to
us a little bit about
what the agencies are like is all of
this stuff warranted is some of our
worries unwarranted et cetera et cetera
no the concern of governmental power is
one of the reasons I ran for congress
right too much too much power in
Washington DC unchecked uh is something
that America has always had a
responsibility to protect against and
you can see it uh I I can speak most
directly to of the intelligence agencies
the CIA I worked with the FBI on some
projects but I I was never responsible
for it in the same way that I got a
chance to peer inside CIA
uh I took over from a man named John
Brennan the previous director who had
politicized that agency deeply uh he'd I
write about this in never give an inch
he he worked on this thing that
incorporated the steel dossier that
became the Russia hoax in ways that were
antithetical to good analysis good
intelligence that is so important for
the United States of America
and I I had to go back and rebuild
pieces of that
but the good news was
and this is different from the state
department which is a big bureaucracy
which frankly
we could talk about as hugely
problematic but different at the CI at
the ca most of the folks are people who
want to do America's Mission and so when
I came in and president Trump came in
yes sir got it this is the direction
you're going we're going to go bang our
head against the wall we're going to go
break through it we're going to deliver
for the American people as you have
directed us to do these are young men
and women who you know they just want to
put a dagger in their mouth and go out
and collect intelligence for us and the
risk is that you have political
leadership and in the end presidents own
that you have political leadership that
undermines both America's confidence in
the institutions which is the skepticism
you're referring to but as equally bad
as that as as troubling as the the the
absence of confidence in the institution
is is they're not effective they're not
on Mission when they're spending their
time training on diversity equity and
inclusion when the green agenda and the
lgbt2 lgbtq agenda come to dominate the
focus inside these institutions
you're undermining incredibly powerful
American tools that have kept us all
safer and awfully a long time so when
you took the gig was it like day one
that you realized how politics and and
the Obama Staffing and everything that
Brennan was doing did you realize it on
day one how how dirty the whole thing
had become and how tough is it to go in
and try to clean up some of that stuff
so I'd seen it even before that I served
on the house intelligence committee so I
had been watching the dni operation the
CIA operation all of the intelligence
folks for four or five years and so I
knew that Brennan look this this is the
director of the CIA who refused to say
that the agency spied on foreigners just
like right no that's that's what its
task is to go do really good collections
so presidents can have good data sets to
make informed decisions and so I I knew
that director Brennan had taken this
agency off Mission off its focus and so
literally it's the case Dave on day one
I went in I built my team some of from
the outside most of it frankly from the
inside that were still great and still
are great people there we identified
leaders we identified people who were
Pipers who were willing to go crush it
on behalf of America and change the
focus of the agency to deliver for the
president
so how has that now changed since you're
gone and obviously we have a new
Administration and I suspect they
probably like a lot of those Brennan
appointments that were there
and ideas yeah yeah it's it's different
um I will say this the current director
director Burns is not John Brennan
uh and so I think that's I think that's
fantastic John along with director Comet
the FBI were a pair of truly Bad actors
who and I write about this in the book
who on January 6 2017 when the president
had not yet been sworn in went to Trump
Tower I was invited to be there I was
still just a member of Congress I was
the nominee to be the CI director went
to Trump Town basically told Donald
Trump that he was a Russian asset or
that they believed so and I am now even
more convinced that they knew that
wasn't true that they knew it was based
on unreliable unverified for sure
information and the harm that they did
forget to me or to Donald Trump the harm
that they did to our country is just
among the most dangerous things I have
seen come out of the intelligence
community in my lifetime what do you
make of how nobody seems to ever pay a
price for these things so when you talk
about you know the Steele dossier coming
out of this or the 50 former
intelligence officials that basically
said the hunter Biden laptop was Russian
disinformation which we know obviously
it now was not I think one of the
frustrations for average people is they
they see this and they go well nobody
seems to ever get fired actually the
people who lie end up with gigs on CNN
or in the government
yeah one of my biggest challenges was
John Brennan was out there on MSNBC
talking about all this stuff while I was
trying to run the CIA it was uh it was
usually problematic because you had some
fraction of the workforce though wanted
to follow him and more importantly you
had this are you guys not told
beforehand I don't know who would tell
you but I mean is it shouldn't there be
some sort of code like if you ran the
thing you can't be on MSNBC or Fox a
week after you leave to to tell the
students yeah yeah and by the way that
was common practice a pretty common
practice look I don't have any problem
if what you're going out there is to
talk about the greatness of the
institution that you let in the people
really the people right but when you're
out there telling stories to your point
about the the Russia hoax John Brennan
and the folks who signed that document
clearly knew that this was likely not
Russian disinformation and so they
caveat it to be clever but the truth is
I think they all knew but they had a
political agenda and that's that's the
danger
um
you know these institutions matter an
awful lot
um we haven't spent as much time talking
about the FBI but to your point about
accountability we know that McCabe lied
we know that the FBI concluded that
McCabe lied and you know he's out on CNN
telling stories uh pretending he was a
good actor inside that institution when
in fact he along with the cohort around
him undermined the most basic principles
of our Republic
who do you really put the blame at with
all of this like do you feel that that's
a Brennan to blame or was that purely
that he was doing basically what Obama
appointed him to do
you know Dave I always hold the senior
leaders accountable
and and that holds true for our
administration too the things we got
wrong were my responsibility of the
president's responsibility this isn't a
partisan shot the Iowa President Obama
responsible in fact with respect to this
dossier and the intelligence report that
was written Obama had directed that
report be written and publicized uh in
the fall of what would have been 2016.
after the election he directed that they
write this report and that they make a
classified version an unclassified
version that was released that that's
unheard of to have that happen and so
this was directed from the highest
levels uh last thought people matter and
so every president has to be incredibly
focused from before day one on bringing
the right people in that not only share
their policy views but their value set
and I think you can see one of the
things I regret is that director Comey
wasn't replaced immediately at the
beginning of our Administration he sat
inside of our team while he was trying
to undermine everything it was that we
were doing so do you blame your former
boss for that like do you think he was
just not didn't realize the magnitude of
the problem so because that is one of
the things people say hey Obama you may
not like what he did but he did staff
these places the way that he wanted
while while Trump didn't realize how
many layers down something to that
effect that's one of the the kind of
memes out there on this thing yeah I
even think president Trump himself has
said that he you know he came in new
without knowing a whole lot of folks in
town which was a positive a good thing
I'm I'm in support of that but also had
the downside of the fact that he had
some missteps at the front end in terms
of people uh the second thing is is we
didn't get our team on the field so not
only were there some selections that
weren't the right ones we spent an awful
lot of time waiting for our folks to get
uh get the clock get the clearances
complete get the Senate to confirm them
get them in position we lived the first
year and a half or two of our entire
time of half of our time uh working with
folks who had been appointed by a
president other than the one that the
people had elected in November of 2016.
that's bad whoever the next conservative
president is they've got to get that
right they've got to show up day one
helmet on ready to drive these people
into the team so that we have our team
we have our leaders they are out
executing with a viciousness that is
required to push back against the
administrative State So speaking of that
administrative state I'm sure you've
seen some of the Twitter file leaks and
the and the emails that went from
intelligence agencies to the employees
at Twitter I mean were they overstepping
their bounds and and at what point is
that a violation of our first amendment
if the government is in essence coercing
a company to silence people yeah you you
can either have command and control or
you can have coercion in this case right
and the net effect is identical uh I
think you can think you can pretty
clearly see this was coercion so lawyers
can all tell us whether that invokes the
first step right or if you have
government action or not I I don't
really well here's what we know we we
know with absolute certainty that uh the
political actors in The White House were
giving guidance to these folks to censor
conservative ideas not Viewpoint neutral
not uh this is not about keeping the
Taliban or Isis off of Twitter this is
about political actors seeking to
manipulate speech in America in a way
that promoted a governmental viewpoint
that is dangerous I'm happy to say that
the American people can see it because
in the end Dave you know this most of
the recourse to your point about
accountability most of the recourse
comes through political accountability
uh justice departments are responsive to
the presidents that put them together
while they have a element of
Independence make no mistake about the
attorney general works for the president
United States of America and we can see
that playing as day to day in the way
Merrick Garland is delivering this
justice department and weaponizing so
much of what they're doing there so
let's let's talk about that actually
because obviously the big thing at the
moment are these classified documents
you know we went through six months ago
what Trump had at Mar-A-Lago and the
president is allowed to declassify
things but you know the media was
telling you the walls are closing in
again and okay it doesn't seem as as if
much has happened but now Biden's in the
midst of one of these scandals himself
what should the policy what actually is
the policy on this sort of thing like
one of the things that I've heard Biden
say a couple times is well it was a
small amount of documents as if that
somehow makes it a little bit better I'm
pretty sure you don't want any
classified docs out right is that is
that fair to say it seems right if it's
classified it has a place and it place
isn't next to your Corvette in the
garage by the way it's also not at
Mar-A-Lago uh and by the way it wasn't
on your uh Blackberry when you were
Hillary Clinton the first time I dealt
with this when I sat on the Benghazi
committee with Jim Jordan and Trey Gowdy
when you had senior American officials
exchanging classified information across
an unsecured blackberry and you had all
this stuff in the server up at Hillary
Clinton's place in New York I lived this
where we were trying to unpack exactly
the risk she had created to America by
doing this my theory on this one again
not partisan classified information
protected if it shouldn't be classified
if it's over classified fine
Declassified get it out release it to
the Washington Post sign me up but if
the decision was that this is needed to
protect an American secret or American
soldiers or Sailors or Airmen and
Marines somewhere in the world then for
goodness sakes no we're not a president
not a CI director or Secretary of State
no one should be absolved from
responsibility for managing that
information appropriately and so I hope
this will be managed in a way that is
neutral and I'd say one last thing Dave
neutral in the in two ways one it
shouldn't be political rsds
conservatives liberals but neutral also
and I write about this in the book we
didn't prosecute we didn't get any
anything to Hillary Clinton there were
lots of young soldiers Young Marines who
had made mistakes in how they handle
classified information they were
punished and so we should make sure that
you don't get off scot-free just because
you have power and influence and you are
punished if you are someone who is more
Junior whether you're a gs-12 at the
department of energy or a
young private in the Marines we should
make sure that in America the law is
applied evenly of both both left and
right and up and down that would be
refreshing I don't even know if you're
allowed to answer this next question but
how how do you guys actually decide what
really is that highest level classified
is that is there a standard policy on
everything or do they bring things to
your desk and you have people making
Arguments for you that you have to make
that final call on
some of each so there's a process a
detailed classification process within
the United States government the
Department of Defense has a process the
intelligence agencies each have a
process they roughly mirror each other
but decision makers at every level are
making decisions about how to classify
their categories of things
if there's things about operatives
somewhere in the world it gets a certain
classified so there is a rubric designed
to try and get these classification
levels right uh look at the edge I'm
sure there's people making judgment
calls maybe some of them political I I
didn't see much of that inside the CIA
mostly I saw people trying to get it
right and then there were many many
occasions when things were brought to me
and for whatever reason I wanted them
Declassified I felt it was important
that the American people knew I thought
that the risk whatever that might have
been two years ago five years ago was
diminished and so I would send back down
say we needed to classify this a little
bit of process but in the end between
the senior leadership and the president
we could always get it to the right
level of classification every handful of
times I went the other way I saw
something like what the what the heck is
that doing at free space we need to try
to make sure we secure that information
at least for a little while are you
worried at all that as people kind of
see how
dysfunctional Washington is or just how
crazy the machine seems to be as we've
you know because of Technology we can
look under the hood now in a way that
you couldn't say 40 years ago that that
we're not going to get the quality
person that you want working in these
agencies because people are just going
to say no I'd rather be in the private
sector I just see this thing as a as a
big freaking mess I mean I understand
you're saying there's obviously a lot of
great people there but that over time
that there will be a a sort of uh a
draining of that
yes I'm worried about in two respects
one in the true sense that you describe
good people will decide not worth the
candle yeah for financial reasons family
reasons who needs the headache reasons
all the above the second reason I worry
about this and I and I write about this
and and this is why you can't give an
inch
that's why I titled the book the way I
did the bias will be the people of the
left will say yeah I want to be part of
government and conservatives will say
I want to go live my life uh right
um and uh that bias I think already
exists inside these bureaucracies where
I I come from a place where government
is something that you look at you go
yeah I'm a little skeptical and the
private sector should be flourishing and
delivering in churches and synagogues
and Boy Scout Troops that's the place
America was made and so conservatives
tend to say you know I'm good I'm living
here I'm living my great life in Texas
are my wonderful life in Southern
Illinois wherever you are and say you
know I went out and go to Washington for
and Liberals are dying for that power
and so not only not only do you have a
net decrease in talent that I worry
about and Excellence
um but you'll get a bias the best people
who are conservative thinkers uh people
who are good operators will say nah you
know I'm not going to go do that what do
you do about that I mean that one seems
almost unwinnable to me because that's
just the nature of power versus the
individual and you're just gonna
self-select out because you want to go
do something in a functional free
atmosphere and that's not really the
government I mean is there any solution
to that yes I'm gonna I'm gonna provide
the solution right now wow to your
entire audience all right go spend some
part of your life serving
doesn't have to be in Washington DC it
doesn't even have to be in government
but you know different people will be in
different parts of their life take a
couple years four years two whatever it
is and go surf you can do it as a deacon
at your church you can do that coaching
someone's little league baseball team
you can do it in Washington DC you can
run for city council or even better
still run for school board and go fix
the crap that's being taught in our
schools today and so I'm not only going
to tell you that there's a solution to
this I'm going to I'm going to be part
of the solution by urging people who who
share our value system who understand
the judeo-christian heritage of America
in the most fundamental way and say all
right I get it it's really wonderful to
be out here living my own life but at
some point in your 20s in your 30s and
your 50s whatever go spend a little bit
of time this is the greatest nation in
the history of civilization and we each
can find a way and a place to give back
just a little bit so let's let's shift a
little bit to the to the second portion
of your job in the Trump Administration
so you had about it was about a year
plus right as CIA director and then you
had the last couple years as the
secretary of state did you expect that
kind of transition did the phone just
ring one day were you looking for a new
gig
yeah a little different than that I got
a quick heads up
um that the president was thinking about
making a change it was apparent to the
whole world that he wasn't pleased with
the current Secretary of State or then
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
um so that didn't come as a surprise to
me but I got a little bit of heads up
from then Chief of Staff Kelly and then
one day the president asked me to stay
behind after I had briefed him and said
hey I'm thinking about making this
change I'm thinking about maybe you
I loved what I was doing Dave
um and I had a lot of work to do still
at CIA and so it was very mixed feelings
but in the end when President asked you
to serve you do it uh that was a couple
weeks later I think uh he called me and
said hey I I want you to come do this I
of course immediately said yes sir here
we go uh helmet on let's get after it
and what kind of shift is that because
obviously these are extremely different
positions
big shift uh you you had the glory at
the CIA of never having to deal with the
media and immediately moved to the state
department where they are front and
center and they sit in the back your
airplane when you travel around the
world
and you had a team that was much bigger
uh 70 000 or so people at the United
States Department of State and you also
had a bureaucracy that had three unions
a set of Civil Service rules that mean
you essentially can't fire anybody a
fundamentally different institution that
also had good people but who
it is it is a left of center
organization but even more troubling it
is an establishment organization
so whether Republican or Democrat that
institution that the inertia inside of
the Department of State was something
that we all just struggled to light a
fire on get after them make them
effective make them efficient and turn
their focus on delivering putting
American people first in the way that
President Trump and I were thinking
about our place in the world but you got
stuff done I mean we got a couple we got
a couple peace deals in the Middle East
which I thought everybody was for my
whole life everyone was for that sort of
thing suddenly when Trump does it it's
no good right it it turned it turns out
that we didn't get the uh the planets
that it so deserved but you know in the
end it's about getting Kudos in the end
it's about delivering good outcomes
these Abraham Accords and I spend a fair
amount of time talking about it wasn't
just me Jared Kushner Stephen mnuchin we
had two great ambassadors David Friedman
uh and John rokulta in the Emirates we
had a great team just working this
problem set
with the Lord blessed us with prime
minister Netanyahu Donald Trump Muhammad
bin Salman and the kingdom mbz and the
Emirates great leaders who were prepared
to take some risks
and the great news is we got peace these
nations now aren't trying to wipe Israel
off the face of the earth that is a
wonderfully good thing but importantly
for the American people uh that the
chance that we have to send our kids to
fight and die in the Middle East now is
lower
there's more stability more Prosperity
more peace and as I always thought about
it that was the best outcome of the
Abraham Accords the fact that we now
have friends and partners we had
isolated Iran and it was much less
likely that some presidents someday is
going to announce that we're deploying
Marines and soldiers and Air Force guys
and gals to the Middle East to fight
some Middle East War America doesn't
need that the Middle East doesn't need
it and that's why I'm just so happy that
we were able to get that done it's so
weird because even though it was only
you know basically three years ago it's
like it feels like a real distant memory
that this Administration that you know
at first they were saying don't even say
Abraham Accords and they really didn't
want to give any credit how how tenuous
was it as you guys were making these
deals like did you feel like at any
moment the whole thing could fall
through or there was going to be a leak
that was going to ruin it for another
country or whatever else
and if we we suffered lots of leaks and
leaks on this particular
uh this particular effort were very real
and put a lot at risk because you had
Middle East leaders taking real risks
inside their countries the historic
argument that the street will rise up
and they'll be rioting and bad things
and they'll overthrow regimes and the
Palestinians will you know start uh
creating chaos there'll be world war
three it was very real that didn't
change uh that perception didn't change
um so yeah it was tenuous till the end
none of these deals are ever over till
they're over we had to get a lot of
moving Parts headed the right direction
at the same time and so there was
complexity but it took and it took us
two and a half years to actually deliver
from conceptual idea to execution on the
south lawn of the white house uh a
glorious day good stuff for those
countries and important for our country
too what kind of pushback did you guys
get from that that sort of state that
you described of these people that don't
change much because I I had Netanyahu on
about a month and a half ago and that's
what he was talking about that all of
the policy people said you do it the
other way you do the Palestinians first
and then the rest will have happened but
he said no we're going to try it this
way and it actually worked but in
essence you're saying these guys they
don't like change so I'm guessing you're
getting pushed back from your own people
as these things are happening of course
and you can see that by the way when we
leave they immediately begin to to fudge
a little bit on where the embassy is
going to be whether it's really going to
be in Jerusalem or we're going to have a
consulate there too for the Palestinians
so you could see the machines start to
push back against it even after we leave
but we certainly suffered that
uh we were mocked right Jared's proposal
was called you know deal of the century
just dripping with uh dripping with
sarcasm but in the end we we understood
something I think that
frankly Republican and Democrat
administrations alike hadn't recognized
we came to believe that these nations
the Gulf State Arab Nations knew that
the Palestinian cause was important but
it wasn't their highest priority that is
um I I want good things for the people
that live in Judea and Samaria what
whatever ethnicity whatever religion
they are I want good things for people
in Saudi Arabia and the Emirates but in
the end we're going to go deliver good
outcomes and Abu mazim the leader of the
Palestinians and the in Judea and
Samaritan he's a terrorist and there was
no chance that guy was going to cut a
deal so we didn't waste any time trying
to get a deal done right to draw lines
on the map we just we we threw that out
uh in the way that bush and Obama and
all of them had tried to negotiate we
knew there was a solution that said
we're happy to work on the Palestinian
issue happy to drive towards the
conclusion but in the meantime we're
going to go deliver peace in the region
and we did
do you think uh either in that region or
really all over the world that that
other countries kind of miss that
American leadership that does seem to be
lost as I said I just did an hour show
on the world economic Forum we seem to
be Outsourcing all of our decision
making to groups that have nothing to do
with our laws or our founding or
anything like that
I don't have to guess I know it to be
true
um I still stay in touch with a handful
of folks around the world who call me
and say what the heck is going on and
it's not even just um
Dave it's not even that we agreed with
him always we had what big knock down
drag out fights with friends uh with
allies with our adversaries but you
could when I was a secretary of state
you could get me on the phone you could
have a serious conversation I would tell
you very much what America was going to
do how we were going to behave I would
listen take on board their ideas if we
could make it work we would but you
didn't have to guess you didn't have to
wonder I wasn't apologizing for America
every every day I was talking about
America as a Force for good in the world
and I think I think that leadership in
the world is something that these
nations even those that aren't
particularly friendly to us I think
those Nations missed that that true
north anchor inside the United States
yeah it's interesting because our media
seems to hate it more than the countries
right the other countries seem to want
it that's what you're saying but it's
our our own media which seems to
actively despise our ability to have
influence
you see this
um you see this in every every element
of American policy not just in our
national security policy uh right in our
schools they're teaching kids that
America is a racist Nation there's an
oppressor class in our universities they
can't understand that there's just two
genders right these are these are ideas
that undermine the central propositions
that have made America so exceptional
for 250 years and whether it's the
national security or education at home
or uh crime always these folks are
working the edges and uh you know I've
had some folks say Mike you have to
compromise you're a diplomat you have to
give an inch but the truth is there's
places you can compromise if my son
wanted to go to bed at 8 30 and I
thought eight was the right time 807
sounds good right
but on things that really matter the
American value system the central
understanding is of family
um the the idea that this is in fact the
most noble Nation to ever exist in the
history of Civilian and those things you
can't round the corners you can't
literally because once you begin to say
well you know it's a good point you're
done because they will drive a truck
through the damn thing and we just
simply can't let that happen
so what do you think is really going on
here with this globalist situation and
these meetings that they have in Davos
and all these other places where a whole
bunch of people nobody seemingly to
represent the United States nobody to
represent the individual we Zen we send
Americans there but they very rarely
talk about America actually on my show
the other day we played a clip of 2018
when President Trump went and he started
talking about America and they were not
very happy with him what what is the
actual influence of these groups like is
it is it as scary as it seems when we're
watching these clips on on YouTube and
everywhere else
you know I I actually think some of this
is just a bunch of gas bags meeting to
have confabs I hope you're right yeah uh
but look there there is a there is a
globalist agenda out there um it's
centered at Turtle Bay in New York at
the United Nations where that is that is
the Hub that is the focal point that is
the quasi-governmental organization the
NGO that that drives much of this
narrative it then bleeds over into
uh human rights activism from the left
and into American and Global businesses
as well who don't stand up to the
political pressures that they need to
but I I don't worry as much
about uh places that where these folks
go to to gather some of them are just
there doing commercial deals that'll end
up being really great to create tens of
thousands of jobs for the United States
of America
um I worry about these I worry about the
United States government and its
unwillingness to accept that most of
these institutions uh the UN
um the iaea I could go on the WTO they
have undermined American sovereignty and
we've allowed that to happen and the
Chinese have figured out how to run many
of those institutions those those are
the places that actually exert influence
and power and have the capacity to shape
both American thought and the way
America engages in the world and you
know you don't have to leave the U.N but
you better make damn sure that you are
not permitting the United Nations to
behave in ways that undermine America
and we never allowed that to happen they
could at least pay their parking tickets
right isn't that a huge Scandal every
year they don't pay their parking
tickets yes they should they should pay
their parking tickets and they should
stick to their knitting as well were
were you surprised by Trump's instincts
on that as a guy who wasn't part of the
political class that that really was
like one of his main things from beat
one you guys are going to pay what you
owe we're not going to foot the bill on
all this we're not just going to give
you endless resources but he just kind
of got that right right away
not surprised at all he campaigned on it
he intuitively understood it uh business
guy came from The Real World what do you
pay your bills right
um and if you don't bad things happen I
have to file bankruptcy right he'd lived
he'd lived all of that in his life uh no
he he understood to
um that these things aren't infinite so
we can survive in America spending a
whole bunch of money all across the
world for a while but in the end you got
to make sure you take care of the things
that matter most to people back home and
he he grasped that in a way that so many
did not and I think America was better
off as a result of that so you were
Secretary of State during covid and uh
that kind of that kind of changed the
world can you talk about that a little
bit yeah
uh so a couple things one I ran a
massive Airline for a bunch of months we
had Americans stranded all over the
world we brought back a hundred thousand
plus Americans who had roadways buses
airplanes pulled out from under them and
so we went and tried to round them all
up which was amazing work the state
department actually I gave them full
credit for having managed this process
to help get these people back home out
of uh tough places but more broadly uh
it gave us two opportunities and a
couple challenges uh first challenge was
look this virus almost certainly came
from the Chinese lab and we were
immediately I think I said this on a TV
show in March of 20 uh maybe it's April
and you know just pillory
you know I was a a racist in the
anti-china racist nope it came from the
lab almost certainly also China Chinese
is not a race but that's a different
thing but okay no it's uh it's all crazy
yeah
um
but even more important than where it
came from the Chinese leadership knew
that they had a pretty damn contagious
relatively lethal virus on their hands
by the fall of 19.
and decided to put tens of thousands of
people on airplanes and murder and I say
that intentionally murder
hundreds of thousands of people all
across this country uh they had a choice
to make the choice they made was load
airplanes send them to Milan Italy uh
the Chinese Communist Party must be held
accountable for this look they don't
care about human life
so be it but when you when you transmit
that to the rest of the world and you
kill people all around the world there's
a place for real accountability
um the good news is I think Americans
came to see how bad the Chinese
Communist Party really was the risk to
America if we outsourced all of our
Manufacturing
certainly semiconductors and national
security stuff but think basic things
like simple Pharmaceuticals uh uh the
capacity for uh our medical system to
operate without Chinese Supply chains I
think American people can see that that
was a bad idea and those businesses are
starting to come back to America and to
places that we can count on to Partners
and friends and that is a good thing uh
the last thing was covet had the upshot
of giving parents a crack and a window
into what their kids were being taught
in schools and ain't no mama wants their
kid to be taught that America is a
racist nation and that Math and Science
and reading don't matter and I think
we've seen a fundamental transformation
about how parents think about public
education they want to make sure their
kids get a fair shot at the American
opportunity and I was all across the
country last year campaigning for
candidates it didn't go as well as I
would have hoped but I was out there
grinding away listening to folks and
they are serious about about this and
you know the fact that we were all we
were all watching more closely what our
kids were up to I think is a net good
thing for America yeah and by the way
it's happening right now I mean Kim
Reynolds is doing school choice in Iowa
uh Huckabee's going to be doing it in
Arkansas clearly something's good you
know something Good's happening here in
Florida but on the first part of that
when when you guys realized that in
essence it was coming from China either
fully intentionally or not or then they
were sending these planes at first to
Italy and then everywhere uh I'm
guessing you got on the phone with some
sort of Chinese counterpart I mean did
they just Stonewall you on everything
did they admit anything was there any
level of accountability or anything
total Stonewall I tell this story it's
an important story as we rounded from
2019 into 2020 uh
the CDC they all had counterparts in
China and they'd been talking because
there was this rumor about what was
going on there and right at the first of
the year total shutdown locked out I was
asked by Mr Redfield to call my Chinese
counterpart the foreign minister and the
state Council I did nothing not a word
the World Health Organization gets shut
out when they try to investigate sadly
they just bent a knee and said nope
everything nothing to see here folks so
the who failed the world as well but
yeah they went into complete information
lockdown uh hiding from the world what
they most certainly knew about what had
happened there how do you as the
Secretary of State coordinate or work
with those you know the who the NIH and
CDC all these things I mean you're
dealing with borders and planes and all
of that stuff are you directly telling
are they basically telling you you've
got to shut borders and you can't do
this and you got to do that like who
who's actually in charge at that point
yeah so the senior decisions about what
America was going to do in the response
where by President Trump himself with
the advice from me and from the
Department of Defense from NIH to CDC
all of his advisors were around the vice
president led the response task force
but in the end they had big decisions
about whether to close our Borders or
not were made by the president do you
guys think you botched anything I mean
if you were to look back the would you
have done this differently or that
differently or advised him differently
or anything
you know I thought about this a lot uh
there in perfect hindsight you can see
that there was information we didn't
know or we weren't thinking about quite
right I think we got good pieces of the
actual physical response right but I
think we got some of the messaging wrong
and then as time moved on and more
information was available I think Dr
fauci uh did Terrible Things by talking
about this in a way that kept our
schools closed for as long as they did
we knew that the kids were unlikely to
have serious large-scale ramifications
from this
we we told teachers or you can stay home
when we told nurses they had to go to
work you know they're all important uh
but why on Earth we didn't open our
schools more quickly while we were so
closing that up and we had churches and
synagogues shut down too uh is
incomprehensible to me do you think it's
fair to say that China did this
intentionally maybe not the leak itself
but that the export of it and when
you're being stonewalled and all these
things that this was sort of the plan to
get Western democracies to in essence
turn against their people become a
little bit more like China rather than
China become a little bit more like us
which is what I think most people
thought was going to happen you know for
the last 30 years something like that
Dave Dave you you got it exactly right
yes absolutely intentional at the very
least we can argue knowing versus
intentional as absolutely knowingly uh
sent this virus around the world and I
from my perspective the difference
between knowing and intent is zero in
this case they intended this virus to go
around and they knew it was going to
kill people all across the globe uh you
know what what were there motives for
that we can all argue about I don't know
I don't know the answer but here's what
we know for sure a decent Nation a
nation that cared about Humanity would
have opened the doors brought in the
world's leading experts wouldn't have
let anybody travel would have locked
down that virus as best they could where
they found it and have given them the
global community and frankly it's
America mostly America's best scientists
the capacity to understand what was
going on there so that you can develop
solutions that actually make sense not
just for China but for the entire world
and they chose exactly the opposite
course so what do we do about that I
mean if if that actually is the case
let's say you were to have another job
in your future perhaps what do you do if
if that really is true
uh it's real uh don't don't kid yourself
about the World Health Organization
saving the lives of Americans they're
not going to you have to take this upon
ourselves we're happy to work with folks
around the world these these these kinds
of things are Global problems but
America is going to have to lead and we
can't do it by providing a bunch of
money to guys at the world health
organizations that don't really give a
darn about
um the second and third order
ramifications of their failures more
broadly for China uh we could talk about
this for an awfully a long time
Republicans and Democrats alike uh
permitted themselves the fantasy that
you just described we thought they'd
become more like us and we've known for
at least a decade maybe two that wasn't
true and we just let it keep going and
we let them walk all over us the Chinese
built their massive economy on the backs
of the American worker we don't need to
let that happen and so I gave a speech
in the spring of 20.
that basically said China's an adversary
much like the Soviet Union uh Ronald
Reagan said we win they lose that's
what's going to have to happen here as
well we're going to have to win and
they're gonna have to lose we have the
capacity to do that we should make sure
that China is treated reciprocally that
is that's a good example
Chinese are trying to build by land near
American Military facilities
Dave I'd ask everybody in your audience
head out call your real estate agent try
to buy land in China near a Chinese
military facility godspeed
we should not let them they're not
giving you no money down on those uh my
guess is your realtor is going to come
back and say it's just a little pricey
you can't get there
we should not let them use our open
Society against us in the ways that we
have and American Business America's
largest financial institutions are all
going to have to come on board come on
sides if we need government power to
coax them in that direction we've got to
do that we've got to return to taking
making sure we take care of working
class Americans here at home and when we
do
we will take advantage of all the
challenges that the Chinese have they've
got issues with their aging population
they've got Financial challenges they
are not 10 feet tall but when you lay
down for them they look like they're 10
feet tall and so we just simply need to
stand up push back demand a world that
looks more like ours a word with Western
values which means we got to get it
right here at home too if we do those
things then the Chinese dream of an
American decline will prove to be just
that a fantasy and a dream let me ask
you about the other big Global event
obviously Russia Ukraine for the term
that Trump had and while you were
Secretary of State it was pretty quiet
under Obama Russia takes back Crimea but
then it's quiet under you guys uh now
obviously not so quiet
um what would you be doing right now
what would you be advising Joe Biden on
and how do you feel about this endless
blank check that that everybody
basically on both sides except for
pretty much I think Rand Paul maybe Ted
Cruz and a couple other guys keep
signing signing off on
uh goodness you know I uh I've been
asked this an awful lot it was quiet on
our watch and you have to believe in a
lot of coincidences to think that we
were just lucky
uh that the truth is uh I think Vladimir
Putin understood that we were different
cast of characters all right when the
Iranians were moving about the cabin we
went and took out costume suleimani
right demonstrating that we were gonna
in a very nuanced way we didn't send 80
000 soldiers we didn't go invade any
place we just sent a message with
absolute Clarity that we were serious
and real and is that your the mother of
all bombs was that you
uh the uh the strike on suleimani was
something that I I certainly recommended
to the president uh and uh I I write
about this because it was important not
just to to deter Iran but chairman Kim
in North Korea who I spent way too much
time with uh uh the Taliban they all
said oh my goodness these kids are
serious pump there are these gays are
these guys are gonna if they say they're
gonna do something they actually are
going to do it and Putin saw that Biden
wasn't that and so you you lose the
bubble and he invades Europe as for what
to do today
um every day this goes on creates
enormous risk for us for America uh the
risk that he uses a tactical nuclear
weapon rest that he conducts a cyber
campaign here in the states to send a
message to us we got to get this to end
I only know one way to get it to end and
that is to provide the ukrainians with
the tools that they need I'm not for
blank checks but I am for if if they're
prepared to defend their sovereignty and
risk their own boys and girls lives I'm
prepared to help them do that against an
authoritarian regime that's killing
civilians
we should then find a solution that has
two features one it's going to have to
be acceptable to both the Russian people
and the Ukrainian people everybody talks
about zielinski and Putin
it's just there's a lot going on here
and so you're gonna have to find
something that everybody can say all
right that is good enough no one's going
to get their maximalist dream second we
need to find a solution that has a
permanency and I lived in there I live
in the real world nothing's ever
permanent but think 10 20 50 years of
permanency so that six months or two
years from now uh Putin's not back at
this or his successor's not back at this
again we have the capacity to use
American power not our not our soldiers
Sailors Airmen Marines but American
power to facilitate a hastier conclusion
to this
and a relatively permanent conclusion
that should that should be the American
mission for the American people is the
inherent problem there I think sort of
two things one that I mean Putin's got
nuked as you just said and to make the
guy with nukes surrender is kind of
tough because he's got the Ultimate
Weapon number one and number two that if
he doesn't get a win out of this if he
doesn't get that off ramp he doesn't
want to end up like Gaddafi and and
basically you know get stabbed by one of
his own people on the Run for the last
couple weeks of his life
yeah Dave it's complicated it's
complicated for both leaders I think uh
each of them have constituencies and
it's different it's not a democracy
nobody's going to go old an election uh
but uh they both have to find ways that
they can move forward
um I suspect that when this ends each of
those leaders will struggle to maintain
their their their power uh the
ukrainians are gonna all look around and
say look what happened to our country
and the Russians are going to look
around and say look what happened to our
country and so uh what I think we should
focus on is not the individuals but the
systems look Ukraine there was a lot of
corruption in Ukraine the whole time I
was a secretary of state
um we should never blink and pretend
that is not so
but we should strive to take a country
that has demonstrated its willingness to
be an American partner and try to
provide it with the tools to protect its
sovereignty and if we get that right we
can find a space where the Russian
people can say Yep this is quote good
enough end of quote I'm convinced there
is very few very few conflicts like this
one end with one side
totally annihilating and defeating the
other the handful of cases maybe the
American Civil War
we might someone might give me two or
three others but boy there's very few
they always end up with some level of
compromise I'm confident this one will
end that way as well and the sooner that
happens the less destruction in Ukraine
and the less most importantly the less
risks to the United States as well
I got one more question for you and you
know what it is already so I don't even
have to ask you I'm not going to tell
you what I'm not going to tell you about
what's in the UFO yeah come on exactly
that's that's actually what I wanted to
know we can do that one off camera but
of course look you wrote this book
you're on the stump people are
mentioning your name your former boss
has already announced he's running we're
almost at the season where people are
getting in on this thing
there you go I'm giving you a song again
we're getting we're getting close to the
time you're right where uh it's time for
those who want to put themselves forward
to make the case to the American people
to do so uh Susan and I haven't made
that uh big decision just yet we're
working our way to try and figure out if
this is the right time to do that if if
we should go make that case uh but I I I
believe deeply in America I I I grew up
uh in a family that understood uh the
the basic decency of our country that
fight is something I intend to stay in
whether I end up seeking political
office again in my life is yet to be
determined Only the Good Lord knows all
right now give me a little something on
the UFOs and then you're free uh here's
what I'd say about the UFOs we got
bigger problems
hahaha
secretary Pompeo I appreciate it and uh
if anything is uh to be announced in the
future maybe we'll do this again
bless you Dave thank you have a good day
thanks a lot if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell